foreign
[Music]
thank you
oh [__] you did that like a pro what the
hell hey for everybody mad at me for
making an Indian joke there's some
Indians in my DMs that I'm at right now
we're resting peace okay no it's not a
joke 400 people just died in a train
crash in India because people were
pooping in the train tracks and the
train got derailed and the whole car
when people died the poop made the train
go off the tracks the poopy tracks why
are you laughing no this is a real story
I'm actually it's not funny I'm
heartbroken I'm about to pray at you pay
for this tonight
damn beautiful morning
good morning SunPass
hey seraphino 8 30 in the morning how
many darts have you worked already
I'm a number one right now yesterday was
a crazy day what do you just rip like
like a full pack I got the video down I
think yesterday at least eight or nine
but usually it's five how did you get
degenerate like none bro oh yeah
three's all right the day before though
I don't know man you got a little gas in
the Box
let's go we're about to head to Granada
working on the artistic videos [__] got
a good idea he's dedicated yeah I
definitely wasn't out before I was a
good boy last night oh are there any
kids out right I hate that that's a
common theme
we're so talented though right now and
we just resort to racism and Beauty
cuties jokes you can only take Yelp so
seriously who the [__] goes on Yelp and
writes a review what kind of demographic
is that Cameron's it's the same thing
with comments on videos you can't let
that get to you my boy base mom seems
like the type to leave a Yelp review if
you're gonna look at the demographic
leaving Google reviews and raiding
restaurants I can see her doing that
yeah she does have let me speak to the
manager let me speak to the manager it's
unacceptable suck my dick
now she's super friendly when you go out
she's like a big over Tipper what was
the lingo growing up in Connecticut
that's lit that's lit that was a big one
you know I think should make it come
back you got Sauced do you guys say that
I miss owned own oh roasted cocked you
had to at all words we were having
light-hearted oh they go straight bro
that's like the second [__] joke the
whole the whole week so far that's not
that bad I gave you some some [__] to
roast me about yeah but to see you know
what I'm not gonna repeat it Stokes why
don't you tell a story right now man 10
000 likes we'll see 10 000 likes and
said he will tell his Horror Story it's
not as bad technically if you have money
everywhere is a spot it's just a little
bit more expensive damn I never really
thought about it like that I mean if
you're above money and there's laws you
get away with for just a fine you
technically have like some cheat codes
after working with the Tates and
Bucharest did that kind of change your
hustle and like the way you work
throughout the day seeing them grinding
24 7.
that was the worst hand gesture off to
the side he was doing this like he did
this four times instead of just saying
he went he went wait
not that important I did this and then
this dude did a whole damn what did you
do do it again
just I'm not doing anything it's more
important to talk about one thing I
noticed is that it's always on their
phone like when you're in the club
you're always working if you're on a
date you've got stuff going on if
they're making terrible jokes just go on
my phone and get some work done instead
like if anything is less important than
what you should be doing instead of
being polite and entertaining something
that's just gets worse like even when
you're sitting around smoking cigars
you're still like sending emails stuff
like that you could be working easily 12
16 hours a day if you can delegate tasks
to the right people and just keep the
communication up to the person who's in
charge yeah that's something my mom
taught me too when I was growing up
especially working at a restaurant is
that there's always something that you
can be doing so like as a busboy there's
always a table you could wipe I mean
this is broken [__] but there's always
like some way you could help the cook
but that directly translates into
entrepreneurship and business there's
always some tasks you can figure out to
delegate there's always some piece of
content you can make checking in with
staff always something to do what you
said maybe really listen up because you
slammed the table with every sense is
that the that was very entrepreneurial
it was very unwalking yeah
see gracias
what I like about Sunny is you're old
enough to like talk about
entrepreneurship but then you're still
like hola like there's a voice crack in
the middle yeah last night we were out I
pulled up with these two guys and the
chicks were like 40. so I just had to
act like I belong there a little 19 year
old boy just chilling with 40 year old
yeah there's not much to talk about with
them and then she just started looking
to her Instagram going through her likes
the rest of the night because I wasn't
trying to talk to her the boys we got
the cold one I was going to tell you
something real quick so pretty program
was absolutely the prickly patch
Ed
enjoy the newsletter join the news today
where are we what is this place called
you don't even know Granada this is
Granada because Sunny can't do a vlog
properly we're in Granada we drove two
hours to be here this is called
nice you got the Vlog moment right this
[__] guy nice man yeah all I know is
it's a it's a mosque and [__] as a
sneaker explainer no I said this is a
beautiful place that you must pay
respect to alhamdulillah that's why I'm
dressed up nice and you're wearing a
beret in Jordans you got basketball
practice and then selling newspapers at
five I asked you do I gotta dress nice
and you're like what the [__]
Guido necklace newsy hat all right I'll
talk to chain basketball people's shoes
bro leave the gun
bring the cannolis
gnoli
you'll look at him bro
now this is content of content this is
what if this becomes your best video
that's definitely not gonna be yeah we
got another video document it bro this
one could be one of the favorite ones
but this one definitely not I'm not
talking about this one he's mid as [__]
hey man don't [__] on my Vlog this is
very mediocre so far
dude
got the paper route at four but the gold
chain leave me alone man he's right
America leave me alone
make your own Vlog bro you have a free
camera man right here yeah I told him to
be vlogging this [__] man okay
oh this is you're missing out on the
real what the hell bro did you spit
for a Clash of Clans joke
I've never seen someone laugh that hard
at their own joke yeah Clash of Clans
won too
spit on his shirt from his own joke I'll
tell the joke now I said he looks like
okay
so he looks like
I see he can't this is
the 400 000 subscribers I have no idea
they're so bad at making content hey man
be nice okay one more time I said he
looks like when you send your Builder
you'll fix the Elixir station
it's not even funny that's not funny
it's not but it's funny because he's
laughing at it
yeah that's what I saw online
right here before you get kicked out
[Laughter]
he literally got lost in the Maze just
now are you serious I had to direct him
or they had the ugliest women back in
the theater are you [__] or no no man
what a weird question every old painting
of like the English women you're just
saying so sit busted bro and what's up
with like the naked babies wait what is
that bro what is what ass sweat ass oh
sweat ass yes bro that's like the sweat
like in between your ass cheeks yeah bro
you start sweating and it gets [__]
itchy that means you don't wipe bro you
need to be the loud Americans here just
yelling about sweat ass and all these
Europeans yeah look at their faces
they're Disturbed they don't even know
what we're talking about man they speak
Spanish the Pearl is the last woman on
earth and you gotta repopulate what are
you doing it just curly things man I
think that's a yes can't post that man
you can post that you can tell her I
said that she'll start blushing that's
gonna be a tall repopulation Nico have
there been any conspiracy theories about
you that like to come up with I just saw
one that you're paid by Emirates to
promote Islam oh I've heard that one
that I've been paid by oil shakes I mean
if they want to pay me I'd like it might
email me might as well get paid yeah DM
me at Seagull on Instagram I would love
to continue performing dawa and bringing
people to Islam yeah of course I'll take
I would take Royal money please no yeah
I'm not griping about it like do that
I'm doing it for free because if you get
paid [__] you know yeah hit me up it's
your hormone monster it's your hormone
monster
[Music]
we're gonna hit some legs
sure you're down for legs we'll see
it took us [__] forever just to get
inside bro at least we're gonna get a
good bike
warm-ups warm-ups
we can't even show this they're just
gonna make fun of the Box come on
let's see what you got man give us some
solid reps bro okay
relaxable
okay all right keep going keep going
oh everybody's injured today what the
[__] why is he doing baby boys right now
the first person to fall asleep at the
sleepover what did you guys do you
allowed to say this on camera I don't
want to talk about this anymore man I
have enough PTSD from telling these
stories I was never going to fall asleep
but other kids specifically your race of
people the white kids in the north the
white kids bagging each other putting
cubes and super glue like tickling each
other's balls how come when like white
kids fall asleep they just start raping
each other what is that with like white
boys and just like oh someone's asleep
let me rape my friend what the [__] it
sounds [__] but he's not wrong I
wasn't I wasn't a part of the raping to
make things clear I like to get cheese
and slap it on people and pour water but
fingers in the butt I didn't partake
there really are consistencies with
races basketball Americans like to steal
white guys like to stick fingers and
butts at sleepovers this is boxing coach
from our bed just send me a voice was
she just at the gym
I hope you're well I just realized it
was you that I spoke to in the gym I
think if I'm wrong but yeah I didn't
even know who you were until I I didn't
speak to any girl in the gym why did she
say that did I should we go back
James Instagram but yeah it was nice to
see you and
yeah you didn't talk to any girl in the
gym no but she say that what was she
talking about sorry I didn't
bro we're in the gym and there's these
pillars in the middle and on the other
side there's these group of girls like
peeking behind I think that's him you
think that's that's him oh it's from
unit 41 it's from the um
the gym the other day
oh
she's trying to oh she probably saw the
kids posting any type of [__]
[Music]
[Applause]
Haram
she was kind of bad though was she I
think I just fell in love with a porn
star it's good to hear from you I was
waiting for you to message me what are
you doing tonight we should see each
other before I leave Marbella I think
I'll be back in the gym tomorrow but I
want to see you tonight
[Applause]
such a mood killer bro
cuties
[Applause]
yo I saw a tweet shout out to my guy Joe
Lambton he was saying like a lot of guys
in the Red Bull space will be like oh I
approached 14 girls in the mall I do a
cold approach five times a day I've
never liked doing that if I could have a
presence and I could build a social
brand or whatever and I could just show
up places and people like oh who's that
isn't that way better than having to
like call the pro okay beautiful like
running lines and stuff like that
wouldn't you rather to show up and then
people talk about you and then they DM
and then boom boom why would you want to
have to risk rejection not only when you
upgrade your character do you get more
girls you also get more high quality
girls so it's like let's say you hit
80xp now you're that 80 overall it's
like you unlock the b cups no yeah I
just don't feel like approaching that's
the whole thing I would rather not have
to go up and like do that no I couldn't
agree more I've been saying I want to
keep going until I don't have to what is
it introduce myself when I walk into a
room exactly how often do you really
have to introduce yourself it's probably
not too often yeah actually you know
it's kind of like shitty sometimes
sometimes people introduce me to like yo
this is my friend Max and I'm just like
like to meet you and they're like What's
your name what's your name because I'm
so used to this like people already
knowing it's not a [__] thing though
you dead ass just get recognized
everywhere yeah my trainer like I had to
spar somebody I was like yo this is Max
and I'm like hey he's like uh
I'm about to punch you in the face tell
me your name
that's exactly how you you whined when
you said it like that bro I just got
started you just did a workout you just
sweat it out like I don't know like why
[__] up your lungs again like you just
you want to go talk
we're gonna do a competition there's
nothing better than fighting oh look at
how many reps I'm doing bro fight me you
know like that's what what beats that
competition you don't beat someone in a
fight and go but I can I can [__]
super shoot better threes than you but
my form
you sound like a game yeah we're gonna
think of this and go [__] me like a
dog right now and now Arab trying to
extend the trip make us work more we go
to stay here for four months
let's do Morocco the knife okay
Casablanca or Marrakech it's one of the
poorest area in Morocco yo look at Sunny
inviting himself am I am I invited
inviting himself
um I'll fly home let's go home
[Music]
stress
what are you doing distress
yeah what I'm just getting a protein bar
it's a good food